au coeur du massif du jura ain vastes
espaces inhabités occupe la frontière
entre suisses et france
ici entre 1200 et 1600 mètres d'altitude
la forêt la neige et le froid ont
toujours régné en maître pourtant au fil
des siècles les hommes sont parvenus à
apprivoiser une partie de ces lieux
sauvages pour y faire paître leur bétail
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui encore des éleveurs français
et suisses se partagent cet univers hors
du temps à l'écart de l'agitation du
monde
[Musique]
norbert borné et le berger de l'alpage
de la petite échelle en hiver son chalet
reste ouvert aux randonneurs de passage
c'est un endroit où les gens aiment bien
venir en hiver pour que les paysages des
grands espaces ouverts décret doit se
mettre le prix bois c'est quand même
assez unique dans le jura où on peut
faire une alternance de grands paysages
et perd près de forêt de le prix bois
c'est donc les agriculteurs qui ont
défriché les forêts tu es donc ils ont
vu tout de suite quand on vend une
partie de la forêt on pouvait donc avec
des animaux faire de la fabrication
fromagère et donc là une plus value
économique intéressante que dans le même
temps ils ont aussi
disons qu'on servait quand même des
milieux parce qu'il fallait que les
bêtes des abris aussi il fallait du bois
pour le chauffage
donc ils ont gardé une biodiversité
assez intéressante qui fait aujourd'hui
s'améliore un peu unique qui a le pré
bois
les premiers témoignages de
l'utilisation des sommets jurassiens
pour faire paître le bétail remonte au
milieu du xvième siècle très tôt les
éleveurs français des vallées
avoisinantes
on fabriquer du fromage à l'alpage
d'abord avec le lait de leurs vaches
puis avec celui de bêtes qu'il louait à
des agriculteurs suisses afin
d'augmenter leur production
mais peu à peu ceux ci ont monté leur
propre bétail à la montagne en
territoire français
par la suite un acte officiel entre les
deux pays
le traité du pacage franco-suisse a
entériné cette ancienne tradition
aujourd'hui vaches et génisses des deux
pays prennent toujours le chemin de
cette transhumance original bientôt
pratique là c'est l'hiver on est dans
l'hiver on pense un petit peu à faire 10
qui accueillirent mais bon voilà
l'alpage ce sera après ça dépend un peu
de la cia eu un gros hiver comme cet
hiver là c'est vrai que ça va être un
peu plus retardé mais autour du 20 mai à
peu près on commence déjà à faire un
tonneau clôture et puis voilà l'alpage
va partir assez vite
[Rires]
cette année malgré son abondance
la neige a abandonné les lieux sans
résistance sous la chaleur insistante
d'un printemps précoce est très sec
le signal a été vite compris comme
partout en montagne la belle saison est
ici de courte durée et poussent les
herbes et les premières fleurs à envahir
rapidement le paysage l' armée
disciplinée des crocus est la première à
se mettre sur les rangs
suivi de quelques primevères et des
gentianes printanière
être la nage
c'est vrai que ça détruit pas mal les
fils l'écran pillon donc c'est vraiment
un travail on peut dire à peu près 2 km
de clôture il faut joindre à une semaine
dix jours à peu près de travail continue
pour remettre en état ce que la neige en
inde et fait quoi
accélération du temps oblige la plupart
des éleveurs français et suisses
montrent maintenant leurs bêtes en
camion ou en bétaillère c'est le cas
pour le troupeau de norbert
[Musique]
premier contact entre le berger et ses
pensionnaires
leur cohabitation durera plus de quatre
ans à condition que l'automne et les
premiers fois n'arrive pas trop tôt
[Musique]
7 ok
un choix pas encore fait
voilà pour les bêtes
après les mois d'hiver passé à les
tables l'arrivée à l'alpage l instant du
premier contact avec des saveurs et des
odeurs nouvelles des hiérarchies
différentes
pourtant une partie de ses génisses en
déjà fait le voyage années passées c'est
la mettront bas à luton et deviendront
alors vaches laitières un accroche
l'histoire trois partenaires donc
le propriétaire du chalet d'alpage de la
peinture
le syndicat pastorale donc de la commune
est en fait les bergers qu on est très
content or donc en fait on décide de
monter tel jour toutes les génisses
tu l'as dans la même commune tel jour le
berger est au courant on prépare le
berger quelques jours l avance pour lui
dire voilà on monte tous les jeunes y
cela toutes les génisses sont montés
donc
en bétaillère pour une
facilité donc dès que les jeunes y sont
arrivés
en alpage c'est la responsabilité
entière des bergers jusqu'au jour de la
descente
[Applaudissements]
du côté suisse les montées se font
également en camion pour la plupart des
syndicats d'éleveurs
celles ci concernent l'alpage de la vère
mode voisin de la petite échelle est
adossé directement à la frontière le
chalet est inaccessible par la route les
bêtes doivent donc quitter les
bétaillères et marché une demi-heure
avant d'arriver à destination
[Musique]
les génisses montée l'an passé en
parfaitement mémoriser le chemin du
chalet et sont rapidement partis en tête
du trop court elle laisse derrière elle
les plus jeunes et quelques mots qui
font également partie du voyage
[Musique]
si l'ancienne tradition de la montée à
pied est pratiquement tombé en désuétude
du côté français en suisse par contre
quelques éleveurs perpétue cette
pratique
ainsi tous les ans la montée à l'alpage
des propos de philippe collet réuni les
différents propriétaires des bêtes leur
famille et quelques amis venus leur
prêter la main pour l'occasion
partis la veille le troupeau est arrivé
après 20 kilomètres de marche au mur
frontière où il a passé la nuit au petit
matin tout le monde attend l'heure
légale du passage de la douane
l'association du pack office consiste à
gérer les montées à l'alpage aussi bien
au niveau douanes yeux comme et erin
messieurs daniel michaud président de
l'association du poker fera que si les
bêtes vont souffrir parce que les
amodiataires ont de la peine à trouver
les apports sur quatre niveaux sur
suisse donne surtout dans le jura il y
aurait maintenant peut-être quelques
encore dans les alpes valaisannes
mais ce pourrait aussi une question de
proximité puisque le traité du bagage
dès que l'on peut monter de 15 km départ
à voir l'oiseau de part et d'autre a
fonctionné pas d'autant de l'association
du pacr tourisme et vallorbe et environ
4000 bête qui monte encore à ce jour sur
france sont oubliées cac 40 50 pages
tissant monteil sur ses 45,1 pages un
seul fromage c'est le monde les repas se
fera jamais le mal si vous prenez c'est
enfin l'heure seul un fromage à raclette
au monde vers bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la cadence soutenue des pas des génisses
est à la mesure de leur impatience à
retrouver la montagne
à tel point que les conducteurs du
troupeau sont très souvent obligés de le
ralentir afin que la colonne ne
s'emballe pas la route et pourtant
longue puisque l'alpage des moves la
destination finale est encore à plus de
8 km
[Musique]
satisfaction de l'arrivée pour les
hommes et pour les bêtes
celles ci auront droit à quelques heures
pour se restaurer et se reposer de la
fatigue de la marche avant d'être
débarrassés de leur grosse cloche
elles seront remplacées par de simples
clochette qui ne les quitteront plus dur
en pleine page
en moins de quinze jours
au fil des montées qui se succèdent la
montagne se remplit de plusieurs
milliers de bêtes rapidement absorbé
dans l'immensité du paysage du côté
français la race rennes est sans
conteste la montbéliarde destinés à la
production du lait qui donnera ensuite
le comté les alpages suisses eux sont
très reconnaissables même pour le
premier venu pas ou peu de montbéliarde
mais un joyeux mélange très cosmopolite
de différentes races de génisses aux
couleurs variées dans le désordre ces
demoiselles ont pour nom val d'hérens
simone talent holstein rouge noir
limousine doublé de quelques croisements
originaux qu'aucune réglementation n'a
encore réussi à limiter l'alternance
délicate des pâtures et de la forêt du
prêt bois est resté relativement stable
au fil du temps les combes et les
versants actuellement utilisés sont
identiques à ceux des friches et des
siècles auparavant ils sont toujours
parcouru par le bétail qui à sa façon en
entretien la pérennité en broutant une
exploitation forestière raisonnée
apporte de son côté une large
contribution au maintien de ses paysages
origine ni au sol des réseaux de muret
sépare les alpages et leurs différents
parcs
ils sont constitués de multitudes de
pierre prise autrefois dans des
carrières rudimentaire ou inlassablement
arraché au pâturage pour en améliorer la
qualité
accessoirement ils peuvent devenir leur
père de quelques autres plus ou moins
fréquentables selon les goûts celle ci
est une vipère péliade une habituée de
certains milieux inhospitalier du massif
jurassien
mais que l'on se rassure et elle est
plutôt rare à l'alpage et bien des
berges et des génisses n'ont jamais vu
le bout de la queue
[Musique]
du côté de la flore le monde du prêt
bois et d'une très grande richesse
tout au long de la saison d'alpage
les génies sont à se mettre sous la dent
ou à contempler allez savoir
une grande diversité de plantes et de
fleurs aux saveurs une forme différente
[Musique]
il
parmi ce cortège se glissent quelques
raretés singulièrement dans le groupe
des orchidées dans certaines espèces
sont emblématiques de cet endroit
vous
même la famille gentiane a ici son
espèce original et peu répandu et la
gentiane croisette
elle est l'hôte unique de la chenille
d'un papillon plutôt rare étrangement
cette chenille se fera ensuite nourrir
par des fourmis
[Musique]
manuel fleurot est le berger de l'alpage
de la vère mood
je travaille avec un syndicat paysan
suisse d'un village qui s'appelle moi
donc c'est un village qui les proches de
la sarre à cossonay les batailles
franchissent la douane en camion mais
ces bêtes sont lâchés des gamins en
balade à grande échelle après ont monté
ensemble à pied
mon travail consiste en premier lieu
disons à la surveillance générale du
troupeau et à l'état sanitaire du
troupeau aussi donc voilà donc j'ai mes
veaux je les rentre tous les jours tous
les matins dans le but de leur donner du
granulé aussi le fait de les rentrer les
attacher salle et docile is énormément
donc voilà après les génisses bah je
vais les contrôler tous les jours qu'on
voit si tout va bien s'il n'y a pas de
problème de mammites ou de boiterie des
choses comme ça au-delà de ça au delà de
la surveillance du troupeau et
l'état sanitaire général des bêtes et à
tout ce qui est un petit peu un trait
aux pâturages
là on est quand même dans une
problématique de près bois ou
disons qu'on a quand même la forêt a
quand même tendance à se refermer un
petit peu par rapport aux pâturages donc
moi je
j'essaye d'éliminer des espèces
végétales un peu colonisatrice genre
le chardon lavéra travers entrant plus
cinq ans toxique pour le bétail c'est un
plan qui colonise très vite donc
j'essaie quand même de contenir ces
espèces là au mieux en fait il faut
aussi faire quelques buissons pour un
peu ouvrir un peu plus de pâturages pour
les battre quoi
retour à la petite échelle où les
génisses de norbert sont maintenant chez
elle dans leurs nouveaux pâturages
[Musique]
il
voilà je te remets il est léger leaf
donc le le but c'est de regarder ça en
bon état sanitaire et donc de bien
détecter s'il y en a qui sont malades ou
pas alors c'est vrai qu'à plusieurs
plusieurs maisons cette observation pour
dire regardez les génisses sur un bon
état du général et puis après bon il ya
des zones un peu plus sensibles comme
les yeux les mamelles
disons voilà la digestion tout ça voilà
on regarde bien en détail chaque bête
pour être sûr car on passe des longs
moments à observer les les génisses là
pour voir d'une journée à l'autre d'une
heure à l'autre défaut à voir si elles
ont le même comportement si dans le
troupeau elles sont bien parce qu'il
faut qu'elle soir la fois bien dans le
court et puis à la fois bien disons elle
même donc le troupeau a un rôle
important là dedans
it
[Musique]
l'autre aspect fondamental du travail de
berger et d'assurer en permanence la
ressource en eau pour le trou chaque
bête ou en effet jusqu'à 50 litres d'eau
par jour lorsqu'il fait chaud et les
quantités en jeu sont importantes mais
il existe ici un curieux paradoxe entre
les averses et les puissants orages
d'été il pleut en moyenne beaucoup sur
les sommets jurassiens
pourtant l'eau y est un élément très
rare
l'explication de cette singularité tient
à la géologie du jura sur les sommets le
calcaire fissuré est partout et l'eau
s'infiltre immédiatement après être
tombé
aucune source aucun ruisseau n'est
disponible pour alimenter les abreuvoirs
et le début de la présence de l'homme
sur la montagne les éleveurs ont dû
trouver une stratégie pour pallier à cet
inconvénient majeur
la solution au problème de l'eau est en
fait extrêmement simple on la rencontre
d'ailleurs sans le savoir sous forme de
curieuses construction disséminés un peu
partout dans les alpages
ceci n'est rien d'autre qu'un capteur à
eau identique dans son principe à un
capteur solaire une surface intercepte
la pluie et la canalise à chaque averse
l'eau rejoint ainsi une citerne creusé à
même la roche sous le dispositif de
captage
beaucoup d'entre elles sont très
anciennes et peuvent contenir plusieurs
dizaines de mètres cubes d'eau liquide
les citernes sont placés en position
surélevée et alimente les abreuvoirs par
un simple système de siphon amorcé par
les bergers l'univers pastorale n'est
plus comme autrefois un monde un peu
fermé et immobile régulièrement dans le
cadre de l'association des bergers
franco suisse ceux ci se retrouvent pour
des rencontres de formation
l'alpage de la petite échelle à 60
hectares en tout il y à 35 hectares de
terre je dirais utile après il ya une
vingtaine fin d'abord vint enfin une
vingtaine d'hectares de bois
et puis le reste est du bois coin après
donc il ya des types de sols très
différents comme ici et là des pelous
sache
le but de ces rendez vous et de partager
les expériences et les savoir faire de
chacun dans différents domaines
aujourd'hui le thème de la journée est
consacrée aux pâturages et à leurs
différentes problématiques avec pour
exemple ceux de l'alpage de norbert qui
a des fois il ya beaucoup de cols chic
ou comme ça donc il faut un petit peu
changer le troupeau pour qu'elle change
un petit peu au niveau sanitaire
moi je gère un peu ça comme ça ayez
toujours des graminées plutôt à feuilles
fines des toutes petites feuilles en
fait à part le ta petite vie plutôt à
feuilles larges au delà des échanges
internes à la profession d à
d'institutionnels permettent également
de faire venir des intervenants
extérieurs spécialistes de disciplines
variées
ces apports de connaissances vont dans
le sens d'une véritable
professionnalisation de l'activité
pastorale de fixer l'azoté atmosphérique
et de la restituer au sol
jean-yves installant chargé de mission
pastoralisme de parc naturel régional du
haut jura moulin pour voir le taux
d'argile en fait si vous arrivez à faire
un boudin qui se tient un sol très
argileux fait que peu d'argile est
plutôt du sable fin limon sable france
voilà de 10,4 cm maximum qu'il faut
laisser en état quoi elle met 2 les
fertilisations là dessus ça sert à rien
que ça va pas réagir comme disent les
cultures
[Musique]
dès les premières chaleurs de l'été
génératrices des orages manu rentrer ses
génisses à les tables durant une partie
de la journée
pour elle c'est un temps de repos à
l'abri des mouches et des temps avant de
regagner les pâturages à la fin de la
journée la tâche âge et de détachage des
génisses aider vous font partie des
rituels important de la journée de
travail de la plupart des bergers
[Musique]
norbert de son côté n'est pas astreint à
l'obligation de rentrer ses bêtes chaque
jour c'est une option prise par les
propriétaires de ces génisses
seule la nécessité d'un soin l' oblige
parfois à utiliser l'écurie du chalet
[Musique]
crois qu'il ya un début de ma vie privée
bet4 des futurs laitière il faut
vraiment regarder les nommer certains
c'est vraiment important comme bitte
orca ya quelque chose qu'on verrait ça
soit pas regardé donc il faut un petit
peu là d'un rendent un peu docile parce
que j'arrête un peu
là c'est pas trop dur donc ça va encore
c'est un petit peu on va faire un punk
ou les titres ayant voir s'il ya quelque
chose qui sort de tout ça c'est
peut-être une bête qui a fêté ses juges
en voilà un début de saison 2 peut-être
demain mythe
donc ça il faut vraiment la soigner un
sms que là c'est une belle une belle
bête pour le lait dont ce serait dommage
que la mamelle soir des gens allumés
juste pour eux pour une petite infection
que
[Musique]
le rythme de vie d'un alpage à génis est
très différent de celui des anciens
alpage à vaches laitières qui était la
règle autrefois partout dans la montagne
l'alpage du monde l'erba est le dernier
témoin côté français de cette histoire
ancestrale ici du premier au dernier
jour de l'alpage le rituel de la traite
de la fabrication du fromage encadre
avec une rigueur d'horloger le
déroulement de chaque journée
[Musique]
ni françois feldman et fromager au monde
de l'erba
les gestes sont ceux de toujours chacun
d'eux est empreint de l'expérience des
années celle du fromager lui-même et
celles transmises par tous ses
prédécesseurs ils sont la condition
nécessaire à la perfection du résultat
final
la réussite du fromage de la journée sur
un choc j'ai fait il a été décidé de
faire autre chose je suis partie
fromager à la montagne avec ménage
jamais vu j'ai changé d'alcool
plusieurs fois j'ai eu l'opportunité de
louer ces deux alpages lagrave dernier
mondial bat le chalet demandes verbales
comme c'était équipe et je suis dit ça
me convient très bien
un beau chalet tout est nickel pour la
fabrication du fromage sans fallait
qu'ils étaient prévus pour me suis
embrouillé jeudi n'est pas tout
sur le jura vaudois on est 24 à
fabriquer dans les enfants je suis le
seul qui fabriquent sur france il y en a
je sais pas s'il y en a beaucoup qui
font du rac latine a peut-être un qui
fait du raclette les autres ni gris l1
fait des tonnes
[Musique]
enfin
au fil des semaines passées depuis la
montée des troupeaux l'alpage et ses
acteurs ont pris la mesure du rythme de
la montagne ici la succession des heures
et des jours n'a pas le même sens que
dans les vallées
[Musique]
seul de l'an et subtils changements de
couleurs d'odeurs et de son marque
imperceptiblement l'écoulement du temps
pour les bergers le travail continue
dans sa vigilance routine attention
permanente ou bête à l'approvisionnement
en eau et surtout à l'état de l'herbe
qui les oblige à déplacer régulièrement
les troupeaux d'un parc à l'autre
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
grâce aux liens étroits que le berger a
su créer au fil des semaines avec ses
animaux ceux ci comprennent très vite
ses intentions
inutile donc d'aller les chercher très
loin du chalet à l'extrémité des parcs
où ils pâture parfois
[Musique]
ce chalet d'alpage de la petite échelle
à une originalité il a appartenu à une
religieuse donc une soeur qui a donc
vendu ce bien à l'hôpital communal de
pontarlier en 1744 et après donc il ya
une succession donc deux religieuses qui
ont géré ce bâtiment et ça a donné un
petit peu cette construction assez
original et qui voilà qui a des zones où
il ya eu des fonctions à la fois
agricole à la fois d'accueil qui ont
permis un petit peu de de gérer en
alpage d'une façon assez
c'est particulièrement les sarandon
qu'on reconstruit cette partie donc otla
et les airs pour venir se reposer un
mois donc dans l'année pour vous la
sortir de l'hôpital et elle avait donc
une chambre ici pendant voilà pendant
l'été où elle pouvait venir passer un
petit peu de temps donc ce chalet
d'alpage et l'histoire de restauration
assez lointaine semaines déjà il ya plus
d'un siècle qu'on faisait de la
restauration
c'est un lieu de passage en lieu
d'accueil tout en menant conjointement
l'activité accrue quand d'alpage
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la petite échelle est
toujours un lieu de passage à gaza met
également un point de ralliement pour un
certain nombre de berger on y vient des
alpages avoisinants mais aussi de
beaucoup plus loin de l'autre côté de la
frontière
le problème de notre seul avantage c'est
pas ce n'est pas un souci on aime bien
aussi la solitude n'était pas encore
très chaud dont il vient de livrer de
l'eau
[Musique]
où
séoul a apprécié ses dépanneurs parce
que l'affichage de la liste si toi tu
sais tu es gentil et que machin me suite
à un copain qui passe ce gentil les
copains qui passent ils veulent toujours
faire des choses des phoques tenu qu'il
ne passe pas avec la nuit met bas il
perd ce machin a déposé trois kilos dans
la cuisine se passe quoi que
ce temps les votes on met les boîtes
dans le boire un petit café
non les vols pour paris alors il faudra
payer souvent jusqu'aux phases sont
attachés l'habite fois les grands maux
actuels pouvoir déjeuner claudine lutter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
brune de lever du jour au fond des
combes
elles apparaissent un matin de septembre
sans crier gare sublime signale des
premières nuits étoilées devenu tout à
coup très fraîche
[Musique]
avant de disparaître sous la chaleur
montante du soleil elle accompagne les
fructifications parfois exceptionnelles
des sorbiers le lan jaunissement de
l'herbe qui s'épuise peu à peu et
l'apparition des fleurs de carline qui
s'étale
ces rames entre la montagne
le déficit
ça fait un bide à celle ayant choisi de
toucher les caresser par le poids de
laëtitia à tout contact dans une maison
on est au manque d'espacé
moi ce qui me manque c'est d'être dehors
chez moi tous bons pâturages je suis
chez moi et la seule pomme m'enfermer
dans une petite boîte
je vais essayer de rester ça sera pas la
même saison il y aura pris de trop pour
améliorer la neige et tout ça et
pourquoi pas quoi moi c'est de ce
déplacement qui me coûtent beaucoup
moins c'est vraiment de quitter ce lieu
où fut bien non non moi voilà c'est la
fin de la page
triste et
petit coup au début notre show dessous
j'ai d'autres choses hiver donc ça donne
c'est quoi ouais moi j'aime bien
l'automne c'est vrai que tu as fait ton
travail
c'est la fin de saison serait celle eric
ott la fin des récoltes tout ça il ya
plein de choses à ramasser les
champignons
moi j'aime bien cette transition était
au top après l'hiver voilà c'est de la
neige m'apprend que redescend dans la
vie familiale qui dut faire autre chose
claude sud est ce encore moi j'aimais
vous qui partent lundi et puis l'autre
éleveurs qui met tout c'est génialement
n'était pas pressé tant qu'il ya de
l'eau et de l'air dont les restes elle
j'en suis fort aise libre est un millier
troppo mais moi je crois que cette année
d'habitude ils sont pros cette descente
de stonehenge et en même temps de
nouvelles je n'aime pas quand tu montes
en douze heures j'attends
le tricolore l'abondance du printemps
est désormais bien loin
l'été est là dans des génisses sont
passés sur l'herbe des alpages qui cette
fois ne repousse plus guère il s'agit
maintenant pour les bergers et leurs
bêtes d'exploiter le mieux possible
jusqu'à la fin les ressources de chaque
parc à partir de ce moment tout peut
basculer très vite
[Musique]
les brumes matinales ne se dissipe plus
aussi facilement avec l'arrivée du
soleil
elle annonce le givre et les gelées
blanches premières prémices de l'arrivée
à présent possible des tout premiers
flocons de neige
[Musique]
- 5° et ar braz au chalet de là vers
mode le jour de la descente
les bêtes ont déjà compris l'événement
et il ne leur faudra pas très longtemps
pour rejoindre la route en contrebas et
les bétaillères qui les attendent
[Musique]
en quelques jours les alpages se
videront assis les uns après les autres
de leurs troupeaux et des hommes qui les
ont accompagnés durant les quatre mois
de la saison
[Musique]
trois jours plus tard à l'alpage des
mots on prend un peu plus de temps
l'heure est aux préparatifs
car la descente des génisses conserve
que mal à monter toutes les habitudes du
cérémonial traditionnel
[Musique]
ici comme ailleurs en quatre mois passés
à brouter sans retenue l'herbe abondance
de perte par la montagne chaque génie
sous chaque veau a largement pris du
poids et grandit au grand bonheur de
leurs propriétaires
[Musique]
il faudra une grande matinée tondez que
comprise pour parvenir à équiper
l'ensemble du troupeau et faire enfin
les premiers pas vers la vallée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cortège du retour empruntera le même
itinéraire cas là d une fois de plus il
sera accompagné du même tintamarre
infernale qui deux heures plus tard
annoncera longtemps à l'avant ce
l'arrivée du troupeau au passage de la
frontière puis dans les villages qu'il
traversera avant d'arriver à destination
[Musique]
dans quelques jours les hommes
reviendront une dernière fois dans les
alpages pour fermer les chalets elle est
préparée à résister aux assauts de
l'hiver
car il ne se passera parfois qu'un petit
mois après la descente des bêtes avant
que le froid et la neige ne reprennent à
nouveau possession des lieux
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]